parce qu'il faut supprimer les
frontières entre l'art et la vie la
fondation du doute ne cesse de se
questionner la vérité est elle dans
cette bouteille tout et n'importe quoi
tout est art l'art n'est rien qui
détient la vérité
low power colonne fit publier un média
par lequel il permettait à tous ces
sujets de péter librement bougrement
culotté ce texte date de 1775 il est
anonyme et fait partie d'un dispositif
inventé par l'artiste den vautier là il
ya tout un tas de canapés autour de nous
qui sont sonorisés qui parle ou qui
disent des vérités puisque c'est la
vérité qui ont été prises dans des
textes fondamentaux
né dans les années 60 le mouvement
fluxus fait souvent participer le public
alors on attaque albert qui répondent à
l'esprit évidemment qui suit vraiment
cette filiation est ce parce qu'il a
gardé aussi cet esprit première que je
le ferai qu'une telle que les cerises on
voulait organiser le banquet de la
vérité donc il y avait pas mieux pour
animer et créer ce banquier que jacques
pour le scénographié
et puis en vrac des mots des images
issues du web à reconstruire sur un mur
qui se remplit très vite parce qu'ici
chacun trouve sa propre vérité je pense
que leur seul au monde qui lui fait
partie de notre existence qu'on va
respirer ou créer les limites de la
vérité se poursuivront avec un bal
masqué des happenings des conférences
les 4 et 5 décembre prochains et ben
sera de la partie
ou pas
et puis le 4 décembre si à
joué-lès-tours il y aura les burning
heads en concert
à découvrir 150 clichés de robert capa
l'un seconde guerre mondiale l'indochine
où l'artiste mort en 1954
plus connu pour son travail en noir et
blanc le photographe excellent et aussi
dans la couleur l'exposition s'intitule
d'ailleurs capa et la couleur fait au
théâtre de tours jusqu'au printemps
prochain
les résidents se poursuivent en touraine
avec par exemple ce dos
madeira m
ce sera au plessis théâtre mardi et
mercredi prochains
il
et l'on referme cet agenda avec notre
oiseau préféré mais sparrow une soirée
filles autant machine c'est demain soir
en ce moment les nuits sont courtes
profitez-en pour sortir
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
avec d'autres idées de sorties